ah vamos ler alguns comentários do vídeo
de ontem o kyle phibex agora fiz ri
demais kaká muito fred mudou o tom
colsoul aqui e joga no gol fred antes
meu nunca vou fazer um vídeo buffet só
porque o tempo não seja tanto é que é
estranho inteira eu já não sei isso não
é as pessoas não sabem escrever direito
à internet como assim não gosto desistiu
do jogo mas não tava parecia vendeu tava
chorando fama ou ou o que está a pensar
aqui ó pá corda
não isso não é de monitores só pode ser
do tcu entanto o fato de treinar só
faltava a pagar a luz agora o [ __ ]
utah fogo
calma daqui tem calma isto é só
tecnologia falhar calma agora precisa
arranjar esta [ __ ] de pc que e isto
tudo subir pra cá outra vez né não vou
ter que ligar e desligar o tumor olha eu
não sei o que está passando aqui vem
tudo está acontecendo alguma coisa lula
da silva foi outra fundida eu já fui o
quadro dentro do hormônio está a pagar
com o botafogo e sobretudo quando é
preciso olha o ps foi baixo e se foi mas
também pessoal eu não sei o que está a
passar aqui eu vou começar a gravar eu
não sei se vocês não o fez começar a
gravar porque eu não sei que por esta
algumas luzes estão acesas ou oito fred
está aceso o estudo já está apagado eu
já tive fora eu não sei se vocês me
considera eu vou encontrar uma luz só
para trabalhar forte a qualquer coisa
acontecer aqui da próxima sexta feira 3
eu não acredito empurra merdas demônios
que nada disso nos angustia pouco toda
eu tô sem renda estava tipo ligará
catarina picada pedir ajuda e não sei o
que está a passar nas duas o tato ou
está tudo apagado e perceba gostoso tem
um sla 16 e som fere e tem a luz acesa
eu não sei que está em terceiro com
muito medo
se alguma coisa acontecer
estão pois o tubo foi eu não sei o que
pode acontecer mas foi perfeito
não não
clay aiken